[Music]
today i'm going to be trying to make
perfect steak using the good cooking
steak stone deluxe serving set now
usually people say you need a cast iron
to get the perfect snake but we're going
to see if we can get one using only this
thick stone let's get started
this thing cost about 65 on amazon this
version comes with this really cool
serving plate and then the sauce cups as
well there is a version of this that you
can get without the extra serving
utensils but this is tasty's money so
let's go big
so i'm pulling the stone out here and
this thing has got some nice weight on
it this is at least a good like five to
seven pounds if not a little bit heavier
so this thing is supposed to give you
perfect steak right at your dinner table
it's kind of like a hibachi grill
experience which we can't really get
right now so let's heat this up and test
it out
[Music]
we have our heated steak stone here i'm
going to be super careful not to touch
this thing because i can feel the heat
radiating off of it you're supposed to
hit this with a little dab of olive oil
do that now and for the steak i've got a
really nice cut of meat right here i
just seasoned it with salt and pepper i
didn't want to do too much i kind of
want to let all the magic happen on the
stone and with that said let's get this
baby cooking i hope we get that really
satisfying sizzle i'm really really
looking forward to that all right moment
of truth here we go
i had to just let you guys enjoy the
sizzle that i heard right there like oh
that was super beautiful that makes me
you can see it's smoking here this you
really feel like you're at a hibachi
experience for real seriously we're
really gonna go for like a medium rare
today so i'm gonna let this thing cook
for about five minutes on each side try
not to touch it too much and then we'll
cut it open and see what's happening
so usually when you flip your steak for
the first time in a cast iron you get
that really nice crust let's see what we
get here it's been about five minutes
oh wow look at that guys
look at that oh that looks beautiful it
says in the instructions that this thing
will stay sizzling hot for about 20 to
30 minutes but it'll still be cooking
for 40 to 50 minutes after you take it
out of the oven so um you know that
show-stopping like sizzling moment's
only good at the beginning but you know
you don't have to reheat this thing
every 20 minutes which would feel like
it kind of defeats the purpose but uh so
far so good so i'm feeling pretty
hopeful about getting this thing cooked
well all the way through the top of this
crust looks super great and i'm really
impressed with what we got on this side
so
let's see what happens on the other side
this is a pretty thick cut of meat so
like i said i'm going to leave it on a
little bit longer than five minutes
we'll probably
sit around seven to ten minutes but this
thing is supposed to cook it really slow
so you don't overcook it so i don't
think i'm going to do that i know i
shouldn't touch it too much but i really
want to see what's happening on this
other side here
what do you say let's take a peek i
don't know guys i'm not 100 sure what
i'm doing like i said the science is not
exact here i've never cooked on a steak
stone before um but you know the steak
is looking really good to me i'm gonna
let it rest and then while it's resting
let's see how these vegetables turn out
all right let's put some asparagus on
here
nice sizzle
boom
ooh last one
wouldn't advise you do that with your
fingers
asparagus is on here i'm really just
looking for this to get like a little
bit tender we'll see how long it takes
for it to get to the texture that we
normally like still have a little bit of
a bite to it not not super soft i think
it would take forever to get this thing
to be super soft anyway i'm even getting
that little whistle too so this thing's
really cooking tongs are perfect for
this thing i can already tell the
asparagus is getting nice
and toasted
it's getting real limp here which makes
me know that like it's obviously cooking
so i'm going to pull this off
you can put it right back in our plate
here no big deal so our asparagus
probably took a little less than five
minutes i'm just gonna put a little bit
of olive oil there a little bit of salt
that's a lot of salt don't worry about
it we're here for the steak not the
vegetables asparagus is done i think it
looks pretty good took less than five
minutes to cook i'm just gonna taste it
quickly
nice and crunchy
perfect amount of salt actually
what's the proper way to eat asparagus
it's so long this tastes really
delicious but again our focus is on the
steak so let's go see how that turned
out
all right moment of truth i've let it
rest i'm gonna cut into it see what we
got here
alright alright
we're in like a little bit of a medium
rare to medium situation here totally
fine i don't think we overcooked it at
all i feel like hibachi style grilling
isn't something that's going to be
coming back right away so this might be
a pretty good alternative to going out
and still being able to get that same
feeling at home
[Music]
[Music]
that is so so so so good the steak sauce
really takes that over the top i think
you got a nice gradual change between
the pink and the center
and overall i'm pretty happy with this
so we just cooked steak on the good
cooking steak stone deluxe serving kit i
think overall the experience went really
well i'm not going to say that you're
getting like a phenomenally different
steak than you would if you use a cast
iron but it's a really cool experience
to kind of have that hibachi grill
situation right at your dinner table and
i think it would be a really really
great gift for someone at this time when
we're all at home so this thing cost 65
on amazon it does exactly what it said
it would it gave us pretty good steak it
gave us perfect vegetables and i'm gonna
give it two thumbs up for sure
well there you have it folks that's how
you cook steak on the good cooking steak
stone deluxe serving set if you have any
other gadgets that you want tasty to try
first drop it in the comments below and
we'll make it happen until then i'm
nichi i'll see you guys later
oh yes
[Music]
you